it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Oh what in the world welcome to
movie fights hashtag movie fights live
more like hash tag movie fights
pre-recorded don't tweet that hashtag I
don't know what'll happen then and gots
to give a shout-out to Al nation
whoo-hoo owls in the house we have got
of huge Titanic oh yeah there's me in a
now let us mean an owl that happened
that is a thing that happened dreams do
come true
that was an owl named Apple thank you
off of my Instagram I mean that was a
mic drop on life for me I mean when I
met that out
but enough about owls we've got we're
gonna talk about the biggest movie um
like ever
Avengers endgame we it is happening
today we have men were assembled and
we're going to do it first up man he
comes in and rules the speed round you
know I'm from Collider heroes and you
can see him coming up on Skybound
welcome back to the party clothes on
drink so much man I love that we're
doing in game stuff like it has not worn
down on me yet and I love the movie was
so good that I literally have not found
a too much oh yeah I've got interviews
with jim Starlin Brian Michael Bendis
and Rob Liefeld this week and in-game
with people that like shaved comics was
I just can't get more give me more
congratulations on manifesting you know
thank you thank you I mean yeah it was
on my vision board happened the secret
works
next up he is one of the premiere nerds
and he bears a striking resemblance to a
certain doctor um dr. strange Maki
welcome back my friend thank you it's I
don't know if you know this but I'm a a
jika hooligan oh hell yeah yeah you love
the owls the the owls
um what exact site nighters finest thank
you yeah I was at Kabul a little snack
Snyder joining and this gentleman he's
the host of the nerd goat podcast and he
was recently on Comedy Central doing a
little stand-up on the new show the new
Negroes please welcome back to the party
mr. ed Grier hey guys it's uh it's great
to be here it's great to be here
these are these are qualified foes I'm
excited because we're gonna be arguing a
lot of Marvel stuff and we got three
premiere comics book Minds I'm very
excited for this threesome and deciding
the arguments weighing in on everything
we have Dan Morrell lon Harris aka
Merlin to us before the show but we
weren't allowed to hear it live reveal
so Dan you are a box-office savant did
endgame exceed expectations little bit
how it shattered shattered not just the
records at shed and expectations going
into last weekend there was talk about
if it could break 300 and how amazing
that would be if it broke 300 million
domestically and it did 357 so it's
crazy I was just telling lon
looking at even at the record yet it
said it had records it's like the third
highest Tuesday and like the second
highest Monday but if you look at the
record books it's the only time any
movies ever done that that's not
Christmas or the summer so it's it's
it's it's almost setting daily records
at this point on April and May working
days and it's crazy it's insanity oh
that's wrong yeah calling SEC go back
and see it again that's how people are
doing people are seeing it multiple
times it's the only way you can get
these kind of numbers right on so uh we
do not have someone on something like
there is no social today
yeah there's no poll since we are
pre-recorded now isn't it so yeah what
are you so what do you do it over there
just gonna hang maximum relaxing snacks
or something that would be wonderful
we are but you will be breaking all ties
you know what we'll just uh the three of
us will be judging each and every round
figure alright yeah we'll figure it out
once again figuring it out as we go
along so again we have a three fighters
first one to four points wins the top
two scores after the first three rounds
will head to the speed round where it's
anybody's game you keep down big yeah
you can make a furious comeback on the
speed round you guys are ready for the
good times let's do it do it
please JT knee drop that sick ass
package
[Music]
I was in Tokyo last week for my wife and
I visited an owl cafe in Tokyo and I
wondered about if all right so once
again thank you Thor so this is this
question I don't know how it let's just
stop let's just call it a day
no we're gonna do it this is a very
difficult question what is the best
scene from Avengers endgame Wow how do
you answer this but these gentlemen will
endeavour to do that what is the best
scene from Avengers end game first up
coy Chandra give a spoil I guess great
point Dan Merle spoilers ahead so yeah
yeah we could not answer these questions
without spoilers so pancakes we will be
speaking enough freely here
so if yeah um you know what run out
watch end game if you haven't seen it
come back watch us otherwise stick
around quit your job and go watch it yes
your job and go what drops out of school
Gordon you can pause you're saying it's
not lime go yes later come on back
alright so in my opinion the best scene
of Avengers in game was the only scene
that had a universal response in all
three of the screenings I've went to it
is the only scene that as you've reached
this crazy climax of effectively a five
and a half hour movie after infinity war
the bar is set these movies tie in so
beautifully together it's not quite a
part one in part two but man it's a way
to watch it there is a scene in this
movie that doesn't feel like a letdown
as you've reached this insane Everest
climax and that is of course cap
wielding Mjolnir we've waited years for
this moment we have been baited with
this moment we have that ideas of this
moment it is a moment that is so ripe
from the comics that it can only exist
universe that is marvel the reason this
is the best scene in Avengers endgame is
it isn't just a scene with one movie
have build up two movies have built up
infinity war to end game and build up it
is a movie of nine movies and build up
it took the cat movies the Thor movies
and the Avengers movies to get to the
point where that would matter that much
and we were misled into thinking Mjolnir
was gone forever with Thor Ragnarok
because it was destroyed so really I
will never get to see that moment oh no
no no we get to see that moment because
it's 2014's mule near which means so
many things had to lead to this moment
and that moment in the theater with a
half broken shield mule near and it's
cap at his absolute finest what cap
represents is one man standing against
absolute crushing odds and it's capped
with two weapons facing off against
Thanos and an entire army and that
speaks to who cap is he can do this all
day he will always get back up and that
moment embodies exactly who cap is after
all these movies and it's the most comic
deep cut you could possibly imagine and
the fact that we're a point society
everyone is standing up and cheering
because of Mjolnir means we've done it
so it's a victory lap in at the best
moment in game alright coy loves them
some Cap'n molnár matki a lot of the
points that coy made are valid points
for that for that scene but I think that
they play even stronger to the one I
chose and that is when you you get cap
him you get cap it and he is broken
shield
it's the that's close to the same moment
but he's broken shield and you get that
far-off shot that's sort of like white
imax beautiful beauty shot in its cap
broken shield Thanos Thanos his armies
caps allies we don't know where they're
at like two of them have been beaten
most of them are under rubble and the
rest of them maybe they've come back
from the the Hulk's nap we don't know we
can presume that probably they have
since Laura Burt Burton with our Barton
was calling her husband but it's at that
moment you're like oh he's by himself
that is the quintessential Captain
America him no matter how badly he's
beaten down he stands up and he stands
up against unbeatable odds and he always
does it and he sits there and you can
get this moment of like almost he is
faithful that even if I lose I've got to
do this like even if I if I go on to a
death it's gonna be terrible and pain
I have to do this and then you get that
moment of cap cap can you hear me it's
Sam on your left and you get a slight
flicker so you know Sam is there and
then you see the flicker and you know
Doctor Strange is coming and then all
the portals start to open and yes I'm a
Doctor Strange fan I know that plays
into it you guys can sue yourselves to
have but the moment that I'm that is all
lead up to this moment where you see
this you see fan oohs kind of a little
taken aback and you see all the armies
like you see what conduct coming through
you see Asgard coming through you see
the Masters of the mystic arts all
coming through they're all getting ready
then you see Valkyrie come flying
through just like it's this moment of oh
my god not only are they all back but
they're all here and then you get Steve
saying Avengers Assemble now you want to
talk about lead-up we've been waiting
for Avengers Assemble since the first
movie since the first Avengers we've
been waiting for that since since iron
man means Nick Fury at the end of his
movie where he says you ever heard of
the Avengers initiative oh [ __ ] we're
gonna get some Avengers Assemble you
know and and that finally happens and
the very last thing and like the the
movies earned that they absolutely
earned that moment where they could have
done that at the end of age of Ultron
but instead they teased it they could
have done it in any other movie and they
did it what they earned by waiting is
that when he says Avengers Assemble it's
not just Hawkeye and black widow and an
Iron Man it's the armies of Wakanda
it's the armies of the Masters of the
mystic arts it's as guardians it's every
single hero that they've ever fought
with they're all Avengers and I feel
like not only do they earn that moment
they superseded that moment and they
they made it a much broader sort of if
you fight evil if you fight wrong if you
stand with us you are an Avenger and
that to me is well worth the 10 years
and the 22 films that we've invested in
this that at that moment to me and
capsulated the entire franchise alright
thank you Matt Avengers Assemble
edie I picked my moment because
it takes these guys moments into
consideration my moment is Captain
America finally getting his happy ending
with Peggy and it is in the same way
that these guys are talking about a
culmination of a long along you talk
about a long time coming mm-hmm you talk
about a long time coming my man's about
to lose his virginity at 95 okay a long
time coming boy you know fact-check that
damn this guy I mean this guy has been
denied due to cosmic circumstance that
of Sisyphus Ian's proportions
you're gonna mean where he's been denied
an actual life and it wasn't because you
know he could have he could have gone
and had a life he literally could not
have gone in had a life so this is after
all this battle and after all these
sacrifices getting your shield beat to
hell by a giant propeller blade you
didn't mean standing against everybody I
agree with you guys moments and I love
the fact that this battle is already
starting off a respectful you know I
mean because I love you guys moments but
I just feel as though they feed into
mine because it is the and it is
actually climactic the people say it's a
sort of an anti-climax after the climax
I disagree because the movie isn't over
until cap sets all the stones back and
and they're waiting on him to do this
job for them once again sacrifice
yourself for us cap once again sacrifice
chauffeur so first god you're the good
guy you're the Boy Scout and it goes you
know what Boy Scout need to eat some
Girl Scout cookies you need to go ahead
and have me a life and an existence that
doesn't have everything all in the
balance I did my job and now I get to
live and I just think it's the
culmination in the same way that the
Ironman Snap is the culmination of a
overarching protective nature
I think Captain America literally rolls
around with the shield we talk all day
about Ironman and everybody else with
this with this protectiveness the man's
weapon is a shield you don't I mean he
is protect he protected the multiverse
with his actions and he deserves a
little R and R or P n R Peggy
cetaceans he deserves it and I think
he's earned it through all the moments
you guys have talked about he earned it
through his participation in those and
that is why I think it is truly the
greatest moment all right cap and Peggy
very cap centric fight it out you guys
so my perspective on it is this that is
that both of these moments as you're
absolutely correct like that moment made
me cry harder than any other moment made
my wife cry fantastic moment one of the
ones that I considered when asked this
question same with with my own ear the
moment that I'm choosing for me best
represents Avengers in game because that
moment is it like the the Mjolnir moment
is a Captain America moment and it's a
fantastic moment there's no denying how
fantastic it is but it's a cap centric
moment and it's the same with Peggy
again fantastic moment I there's no
taking that away but it's a cap centric
moment the argument that I'm making is
the moment yes this in cap is at the
center of this moment as well so it's
hard to make the argument but this
supersedes captain this is about the
Avengers this is about everyone
assembling this is about everyone coming
together to fight this common thread and
doing so together and following this one
man
so I misinterpreted your moment when I
first heard it so it's the entire
Avengers Assemble moment which i think
is a very beautiful moment it's very
powerful it has been led to for a very
long time but if we're may extend a few
minutes to not just that flash I'm going
to extend my my Mjolnir grab to the
actual fight so if in talking about that
entire scene which is I'm gonna say the
moment you have the big three
you've got the Avengers that started it
all you've got the advantage of the most
legacy you've got the only three
Avengers with trilogies and to me
endgame was about ending their stories
we know Doctor Strange gets a sequel we
know Black Panther gets a sequel we know
spider-man gets a sequel that Avengers
the symbol was the first time we had
Assemble but this end game is called
endgame it is the end of the trilogy it
is the end of big three it is the end of
the three that are fighting and the
Mjolnir moment can only happen because
of the way these movies are all set up
to it you can have a team-up movie you
can have a team-up moment like we did in
Avengers so we can have like a liquid in
the age of Ultron the opening of age of
Ultron is that amazing splash page but
you can't
have a moment as powerful as calf
waiting mill near until Mjolnir has been
destroyed until we've earned that mill
near moment until Avengers infinity war
had that lightning strike moment I was
wondering the entire time how they were
gonna top him landing was group with
that crazy lightning like when that fire
was building up with my house they're
gonna have a Thor moment oh wait let's
have a for cap Iron Man moment and have
the Holy Trinity of the Marvel Universe
fighting fan oohs to me the biggest
moment in this is because it's the end
giving them a just ending what end game
did beautifully will somehow send off
all three of our heroes and beautiful
ways I love the Sun off with cap but to
me that can be done in a two hour movie
that exact thing could be a time trouble
it's the notebook with time travel must
I must I must rebut we must improve our
bust
I must rebut because in in the exact
same way that it took 22 movies for us
to get from I am Iron Man to I am Iron
Man
it took the same movies you know roughly
time for us to get to this moment with
cap and I do believe it is an overall
Avengers moment because again he is the
First Avenger other uh other reckoning
aside he is the First Avenger he is the
person who inspired the Marvel Universe
in the same way that Superman inspired
the rest of the DC Universe in this way
that their attorney names to you so that
being the case we must at all Avenger
stories go through Captain America in my
personal opinion that's why we're having
such even now a cap centric conversation
so I would discount the fact that it's
mind as a soul cap moment because you
guys have a little bit more team
involved because we're gonna do you know
extended sequences you don't mean I end
up four moments mine is a really an
indeed a moment and it is a moment for
us to take in that overall the
soldiering and sacrifice he has finally
gotten a reward he didn't mess anything
up he's figured out the time paradox of
where he can do what he needs to do and
get a shield to pass on to Sam which is
just like Oh tears even though I really
don't want that to happen
a lot of levels I don't need a human
throwing that big vibranium frisbee
around uh you know I need some cat
muscles you know but the bottom line is
what I'm saying is I believe my moment
does encompass all the Avengers because
again cap is the First Avenger and this
is finally his just reward and as you
stated they perfectly dispatched the
three movie stars who were just like I
want to go to plays in the park for a
minute all right let's shift gears here
and move to our final thoughts let us
know why yours marines above the other
two and again it's the best scene from
Avengers endgame just getting into
welcome antics with moment scene there
we go
coy so I'm gonna reiterate my end game
mean the end of things I feel that the
cat peggy moment if that had been a
deleted scene from Winter Soldier it
still would have been impactful because
of how much you love can be a cabbie cap
and Peggy who have just shipped as much
as we've loved them from the beginning
that scene could have existed earlier
and been just as impactful I do
appreciate the fact in 222 movies but
that scene was a beautiful scene and
this is a movie for all ages and kids
from 5 to 95 went and saw endgame
I guarantee kids that saw that cat
moment weren't as entertained as they
were with me all in the air wielded by
cat that is the moment for all ages that
is a universal moment that is the
loudest cheer that is action
storytelling plot device comic book
moments it literally when you go to see
Avengers you want Easter eggs you want
story to be told in a creative way you
want beautiful action and choreography
you want masterful directing you want
good acting all of that is in the
Mjolnir scene because you know caps
ready and cab wields it as better as
good if not better than Thor and that
income side capsulate all of those
stories into one so to me that is more
of a scene that's for endgame plus it's
the end of cap as a soldier your movie
is a dane in law it's a button so I
think this for all ages is the scene for
me I love the Avengers of symbol moment
if that had happened in age of Ultron it
wouldn't have had quite the impact but
it would have been a really cool moment
and for me the giant swath of emotion
that we got from seeing all that was
almost so much that the scene was it
became disjointed it became this moment
of chaos with the Assemble and you can
have different opinions about how the
actual Avengers Assemble was said
where's no one's going to argue what the
importance of cap wielding Mjolnir was
especially as it turned into a storm
breaker mill near switch off like
everything had led to there was calm
there was action there was storytelling
whereas this scene was just action which
led to more storytelling but it's not
the encapsulation of Avengers that
endgame that this he wants
thanks coy Matt if I may I feel like
you're missing a bit of the point of
what I'm trying to convey with why I
feel like my this scene is the top scene
it's not just a cool moment it's very
much not just a cool moment I would
actually make the the counter-argument
that Mjolnir is a cool moment it's a
very cool moment it's a cheer out loud
moment Avengers Assemble after they've
been gone we've just we've waited a year
to find out how are they coming back
where are they coming from we've been
waiting since 2012 to find out how
they're gonna defeat Thanos we've been
waiting since Ironman to find out well
who are all the Avengers gonna be and
how are they going to assemble and who's
gonna [ __ ] say Avengers Assemble cuz
like that's one of the very like that's
on the cover of you know Avengers number
four Captain America is coming back he's
like I'm vendors a symbol it's like it's
from the very beginning Avengers
Assemble and Marvel held back they
earned that moment and they chose a very
specific moment and that moment was more
than just the Avengers assembling
because in Steve's heart it is more than
just the Avengers like it is more than
just that core team they're leading an
army of just humans and these godlike
beings in these sorcerers and all of
them are Avengers and I think that that
is just like that speaks so well of what
this movie accomplished it said you know
what mbaku you're an Avenger Okoye yay
you're an Avenger I just said Avengers a
symbol and you're here Valkyrie what's
up you're an Avenger like and we know
that they've had moments in the comics
where they have been this or that or
whatever but like in this movie for them
to have an entire army of like thousands
of heroes behind them and soldiers and
all this other stuff for Steve to choose
that moment for Marvel Studios to choose
that moment for them to finally say this
one thing that we all please Steve
Avengers no knowledgeable journo
to hear it like for them to choose this
moment to say Avengers Assemble
means so much like just almost talking
about it as making me a teary eye
because it's just like it's amazing it's
amazing that they said we the earth we
are the protective net that Tony wanted
we are the Avengers all of us are the
Avengers and we're all gonna take this
[ __ ] down and that to me is why
that's the best scene and I feel like
the entire franchise was leading to that
moment everything after that was Danny
mom thank you Matt Edie okay look man I
don't want to filibuster too long here
man sorry I talked a long time no no no
I'm not done anything passive-aggressive
dude I am I'm saying I I just want to
reiterate it is my moment is not just a
cat moment it is the encapsulation of
the tire of it from the time he wouldn't
that ice to the time he came he came and
got this life that is the span of the
Avengers and so a ending cap moment is
an ending Avengers moment and you guys
as far as a fanfic you if you put a
thousand fanfic monkeys and a thousand
typewriters and they all typed 500 of
those scripts will come out with a meal
nerd moment and the other half would
come out with your moment because we
knew all the heroes were coming back we
know on some level with with a wobble
and stuff like that there are these
fanservice moments that are beautiful
and I'm not saying fanservice as a
pejorative I am saying though I don't
think if you said a thousand monkeys are
a thousand typewriters that they would
have come up with it's gonna be real
satisfying to see cap as a low old man
sitting on a thing handing his shield
off doing all this abdicating and being
up you know and being a little selfish I
don't think if you said a thousand of
these fanfic monkeys of a thousand
typewriters they would have come up with
that and that's the beauty of it that is
the beauty of how fantastic the
screenwriting is in this movie it's
right up there with five years later and
my personal opinion as these very
personal intelligent screenwriting
choices that are not fanfic that are not
fanservice I and and as support for a
moment to be that satisfying with no
element of bring back all of our toys
that were broken to the last movie with
no element of ooh look at this comic
book you read with just a story from the
MCU universe of
this 95 year old virgin finally getting
to have what everyone else has with all
of his buddies who came back for war had
you come back from war with one leg you
still got your wife you still get to go
you know dude do you think he didn't
even have that so so you know I just
feel like the the the accomplishing of
giving Captain America a life after
service was just beautiful he could
finally and I betcha when he sleeps in
that bed with with Peggy it doesn't feel
like a marshmallow it feels like home
and I just I just really think it's
great that he earned that throughout the
course of these movies time Wow
man what a recap of those three scenes a
recap of Kappa Kappa yes have recap and
by the way if you had a thousand monkeys
in a room of a thousand typewriters one
more thing would be true be lost [ __ ] on
the floor dan Merle where we are aware
we fax back zone fact zone Matt as as of
course it isn't going to be in this
fight I have a very useless job because
all of these guys know what they're
talking about but Matt you said that the
Nick Theory said have you ever heard
about the Avengers initiative
technically the line is I'm here to talk
to you about the Avengers initiative
this is the kind of nitpicking I have to
do it for you and you mentioned cap
being the 98 year old virgin virgin
going by the MCU birth date of Captain
America which has been established is
July 4th 1918 and accounting for the
five-year time gap which would put us at
2023 at the end of Captain America sorry
at the end of Avengers endgame he would
have been depending on the time of year
either the 104 or 105 year old
again these are the things that I have
in this kind of a fight Captain America
and the comics first wielded Mjolnir
briefly in Thor number 390 back in 1988
at a time when he had resigned the
Captain America title he was known as
the captain but he just sort of picked
it up and I like vision he just sort of
picked it up and handed it back and then
he's wielded it a couple of other times
in various other comics but that was the
first time and I we are not live but I
can heat much like in game I hear echoes
from the future yelling I am Iron Man
and had all of us from the future right
now in the past I was very super also it
meant taco was amazing I do
America's ass and then strangely the
moment that stuck with me the most the
most heartbreaking moment the movie for
me because I'm weird which is I'll get
you all the cheeseburgers you want Oh
that killed me thank you like but the
one thing that I hear through the four
through the quantum realm is the
intimate screaming in one voice I am
Iron Man and why was that not included I
I have no answer for you I'm in the past
what can I do
get those Infinity stones and talk to us
after thank you Dan yeah you guys really
took me back just I like to vivid
moments sitting in the theater with your
eloquent descriptions of the feelings
that your scenes engendered within you
so and so kudos to all of you this was a
delight to listen to and just relive at
the end of the day it's a tough decision
because you all pick great scenes yeah
it came down to this I think you typify
my kind of framework on what Edie was
saying and as much as the the notebook
with time travel it was a beautiful
moment but to me it didn't resonate as
the best scene it came down between the
two of you yours you're seeing the the
Mjolnir moment was I was like wow you're
seeing I was like whoa and I think you
summed it up nicely
so yeah I mean it's tough to choose
where I go with Matt Dan
yeah well argued all around I think for
me it also came down to COI and Matt and
I think you're closing arguing about the
hold of the fan fiction angle sort of I
jumped off board a little bit because I
disagree a little bit I do think that
cap and Peggy getting together was
something that a lot of fans had
theorized and talked about I I just in
the context of all the rest of the
arguments I couldn't really latch onto
that so it was between COI and Matt for
me and I I agree with you how I think
for me it was the the distinction
between this is a great moment in the
battle this is a great moment for the
character versus this is a moment that
the AMC that was held for years it was
the culmination not just of this film
but of the films
came before it the payoff from movies
that had happened many many many years
before so Matt also won me over right on
thank you Dan Matt you get the point lon
any on any any thoughts on that any fake
internet comments Cordys shout out to
the great Danielle Radford no III mean I
agree with what you guys were all saying
all three great arguments and yeah I
thought Matt did a great job of saying I
liked how his argument was not just that
we've been waiting to see the Avengers
Assemble moment but that it was so
broadly applied all of our favorite
heroes are Avengers together and so yeah
I agree I thought math is rich oh yeah
right on but a great round indeed let's
head to round number two so my hands
like I also considered as like what the
Peggy the Howard Tony is my second scene
that was my second draft pick yeah I
mean two too many good scenes choose
from this duel Sophie's Choice uh so
question numero dos mat key is up one
nil nil now that Santos has been snapped
away who should be the next MC you big
bad know if Thanos has been turned to
dust dust in the wind who should be the
big bad question number two we'll start
player number two Matt all right I am
I'm gonna take a very different tactic
here I feel like we have seen tremendous
villains like we've we've seen Loki
which made a lot of sense for it for him
to be the the first villain since he was
the for the MCU since he was the first
villain for the Avengers we saw Ultron
say what you will about the movie or the
villain or Spade or whoever else we've
seen it we've seen them fight drones
we've seen them fight of shatori army
we've seen them fight each other in a
movie but we've never seen them have to
fight just one of their own and that's
why I'm saying Scarlet Witch
I think Scarlet Witch can be the next
big bad that could it could take up at
least a couple of movies and I'm
building all of this off of the House of
M storyline from I think to like mid
2000s 2004-2005 Dan'l effect check me a
fact check me and tell me I'm wrong
somewhere but house of M is one of my
favorite storylines and it is because
they're the Avengers are confronted with
the question of what do we do with one
of our own like what how do we fight one
of our own how do we fight someone who
we love who we care about but someone
who essentially has the lake and the
comic books at least has the power of
the reality stone within her like she
can control probabilities to such an
extent that she can create a new reality
and that's what she does with house of
him
so I think that maybe we see a movie
where she is starting to like the the
the past experiences of losing her her
brother being experimented on
maybe the Infinity stones that were used
to experimental her are starting to kind
of get to her like kind of play with her
brain I kind of want to stay away from
that you know like the the women are
hysterical kind of angle so like I'm
trying to kind of keep around that but
um because that would be something that
they would need to address but I think
that she is becoming essentially
unhinged due to the life that she's had
due to the experience she's had very
similar to Iron Man in Iron Man 3 where
he's like all I've got is a suit of
armor all these other guys are heroes I
think she's starting to become unhinged
and I think in an effort to keep the
world safe she decides to change the
world for the better and I think she
says instead of no more mutants I think
she says mutants or she says something
like that where she creates this sort of
genetic trigger in humanity to protect
the planet all by themselves so she
essentially says Tony was right we do
need a protective net the universe is
coming for us
so why don't I just change the entire
world to reflect that and all of us are
now heroes and she creates essentially
the x-men x-force act like she doesn't
create the teams but she creates the
mutants that go on to create the teams
and then but that creates an alternate
reality house of em we can get a couple
movies
that may be but like yeah I could have
chosen king but we've had time travel
stuff and that's fun but we've done that
now we've we've had a you know big giant
face those armies but now it's not a
faceless army now it's Scarlet Witch now
it's a now it like there's there's a
like not like a thriller element but
like how do we deal with this like right
you don't know how do we fight our own
like she's not necessarily coming to
kill us but we also can't she's so
powerful that we can't change her like
we and we can't unless we kill her but
we don't want to kill her either so I
think that that creates like a lot of
moral ambiguity and asks a lot of moral
questions and I think that the MCU has
matured to a place where they don't want
to fight like just a drone army or just
like this other army or just like
technology or whatever else I think we
need to see that depth of character of
oh yeah how do we fight this is great
the late a great no not at all this is a
fascinating first answer Matt thank you
and we'll hear from more from you in a
moment
Edie okay I had similar thoughts to Matt
in regards to I've seen a lot of drone
armies that could be turned off when you
beat up a mothership I've seen a lot of
I've seen a lot of this whole jazz about
even even fighting each other though
we've seen a lot of this jazz about
fighting each other and some of the best
moments actually in these movies are
examples of superheroes fighting other
superheroes because of the cross matches
and powers and different stuff like that
and we got a little taste on the tarmac
scene but we really haven't seen that
since it's been more or less the Avenger
is fighting much like the x-men tend to
fight which is big bad in a central
panel they're Russia and I'm from all
four you know angles getting smacked up
and I just don't know that that's the
Avengers bag man I I think the Avengers
are bigger than that bro I don't think
that they should be all fighting one
dude so I think the next big bad I think
we should go away from the central
villain to go to the team because and if
you and I think the team would be the
squadron supreme now obviously
throughout Marvel's history the squadron
supreme have been alternately a joke
or a play on DC's Justice League that
sort of a rib the distinguished
competition as it were but there's so
much more to the depictions of the
characters they actually come a lot of
times from Earth called seven one twelve
or alternately uh Earth a thirty one
thirty one
nine sixteen they come from all these
different alt worlds are what I'm saying
is with all the incursions and all this
jazz that the Avengers have been doing I
think that there has been a ripple
throughout space-time and I think there
are worlds out there that have been
affected by some of the stuff the
Avengers have capriciously done by
marching through time and space now if
you're a team of superheroes on a dying
world or a world that just died because
of something Captain America did to get
a shield or go get some some proto lamps
contra Peggy or something you ever meet
her you you you all of a sudden your
world is dead because of something weird
like that all of a sudden you have a
team of super-powered beings people who
are more like the DC heroes way
overpowered very like the Hyperion is
like Superman Nighthawk is like Batman
dr. spectrum is like a Green Lantern
Zarda the power princess is very much
like a woman Wonder Woman and so on and
so forth at speed care does they have
all sorts of characters and given the
Marvel's a usage of off maligned
characters they could bring counted
enough Arya graviton inertia all these
super powerful people that used to fight
all the Avengers worth it all clicked up
and have a holy mission to kill these
villains from the 6-1-6 who have ruined
their world I think that's a titanic
fight guys and I think it's one of those
things where we could see interesting
cross matches and powers interesting
like super battles maybe have to take it
off world maybe we get people like you
know you know I mean all these different
ways that they're protecting the earth
from these super gods that are coming to
beat them up maybe they have to take
that fight off world maybe we get the
ground or all this weird stuff but the
bottom line is I would love to see the
Avengers fight somebody who is not a
faceless drone army an actual super team
how would they fight they're all the
movies are about them massing around
till they get together to form a team to
beat some central person what about a
better team than you the Hoosiers of
superhero dome coming to your gym about
the place on mass
and you you know your fundamentals are
bad you've been messing around for them
for 18 movies you know so I would love
to see them challenged by another super
team thank you and I appreciate the
Hoosiers uh Dennis Hopper Gene Hackman
fine film uh coy what do you got I've
got the villain we've all been waiting
for I got the villain that we can now
actually finally have thanks to a
certain Monopoly being formed I've got
the villain back that is destiny and
that is Doctor Doom Doctor Doom has
never been done justice fully just like
the Fantastic Four haven't and you know
what we just got what's the next highest
grossing movie besides The Avengers
movies black freakin panther is the
perfect way to bring in this character
we've actually had a movie that leaned
in the political intrigue that leaned
into what it means to be a king that
leaned into what it's like to have this
thing that you're responsible of while
being a superhero I want to see black
panther have to deal with the other side
black panther is about ruling a land dr.
doom rules a land with an iron fist
I want to see a movie where all the
battles aren't just done with fists I
want to see a movie where battles are
done fists and with the pen I want to
see a movie where it's dealing with
diplomatic immunity just being revoked I
want to see a movie where you're talking
about county lines and country lines and
all the things the Avengers would
actually have to deal with some of the
best stuff in Civil War was the the
basically the the superhuman
Registration Act from the comics is
about what it means to be a hero you
could tie that back in to Doctor Doom
with this man as a leader of his own
sovereign nation why does he have the
right to fight these Avengers and
vice-versa if something happens in
Latveria and the avengers go to swoop in
but they do it illegally so now he's
actually in the right so we have someone
as intelligent as Doctor Doom someone
that needs to be introduced through
black panther someone that we've waited
years and years for that isn't just
gonna be space holes that isn't just
gonna be another fight I want to see an
intellectual take my Doctor Doom would
effectively be kill longer meets
Netflix's kingpin I want to see a leader
that loves his country just like kingpin
did but has all the intelligence that
can lead a group just like kill monger
you put that together you give me Doctor
Doom you do dr. doom right he is more
than a worthy Foyle's the avenger and
we've never gotten to before phone Trump
I love how different these three answers
are this is great stuff fight it out all
right let's man III have been known to
be too snarky and mean in these fights
okay you know I didn't want to call your
your movie a civics lesson dressed as a
superhero movie because I don't want you
to call mine just a big punch up because
I do believe it can be seen that way my
idea could be seen as oh they're gonna
flirt other superheroes but it's also a
battle for the hearts and minds because
what we have seen these Marvel heroes
with all their flaws and all they're
just like all they're all their dirty
laundry's on the table their dirty armor
as it were
everybody knows who these guys have of
their identities and stuff they we've
seen them mess up we see them almost
kill us before and and we've seen the
sokovia accords they're chopping
buildings on people all this chance so I
believe that a new group of superheroes
more more like frankly some of the
newest ADC more like other simpler you
know superhero universes come down
they're perfect they're super powerful
they're doing a great job you know
cleaning up messes that maybe they made
and everybody's looking at the Avengers
like you guys suck all you do is fight
and beat each other up and and go
offworld we don't know what you're doing
we have no real connection with you in
five years is past two so connections
actually a good point because you know
what happened last time I introduced an
entire team without presenting in other
movies the Justice League happened I
don't want to see a team of superheroes
I've never met I want individual movies
to lead up to them if we're meeting this
team without any complexity for them any
interest in the characters you can't
introduce the entire squad Beauty
supreme and a bunch of Avengers in one
movie and be invested at all
that's why you go with the solo and in
the first faves some of the problems in
the Avengers had was Iron Man fought
Iron Monger then he fought whiplash oh
that's him fighting himself ant-man
fought the yellowjacket I don't want to
see superheroes fighting other versions
themselves and that's what it could
easily derail into so for me squadron
the screen doesn't allow you to world
build doesn't allow you to invest in the
characters and your superheroes fighting
supervillains
Scarlet Witch I love that character I
love em of house and some we talked
about Marvel movie news for years and
the house I think is a great way on
their shoes I called em of house cuz
you're acting the mutants em of house ah
interesting
but I think that's a way to introduce
amuse and if you make that a negative
then you're inherently putting the
mutants and we've had enough bad x-men
movies you don't want to introduce the
x-men through a villainy plot point
because you have to earn Avengers vs.
x-men so for me using Scarlet Witch is a
ploy would lead to that hysterical woman
problem that we we both want to avoid
and Scarlet Witch has gone through so
much without us investing in there if
she'd already had three movies maybe
villain but if you already give her
first movie maker villain that will fall
apart her TV show sounds like it's gonna
be the vision comics which are brilliant
Tom King wrote the hell out of it
that's a nuanced take on Scarlet Witch
that's a long-form thing if you have
Scarlet Witch be the villain you you
eradicate all of the slow-burn we've
gotten with her so far man you guys both
make fantastic arguments I want to see
all of these movies like it's hard it's
hard to talk talkback against any of
this I will say Doctor Doom immediately
makes me think of doombots that's gonna
be the major thing that they use that's
gonna be the crutch that the Marvel is
gonna fall on doctor dooms gonna have
obviously some great scenes and like
like some great monologuing because
that's what he does but I feel like
Doctor Doom is so uniquely suited to the
Fantastic Four that I feel like he needs
to be a Fantastic Four villain that then
branches out to be a problem for the
Avengers before he's an actual Avengers
problem and again I don't want to see
doombots I don't want to see them
fighting any more faceless that face
those armies and I feel like that's what
you and I have going on over here
I it is it is hard to a fight against
the squadron supreme except to say that
if you really want to have the the
problem of them coming in and saving the
day while you what you should in my
opinion should do is have the Masters of
evil form the form their team the
Thunderbolts and have them start framing
the Avengers for all of the stuff that
they're not doing but there and like
they create fights and all this other
stuff and then they come in and save the
day make the Avengers look like fools
and then the whole and like they get the
world on their side as the Thunderbolts
and then it's revealed you know the
classic twist of Thunderbolts number one
oh my god domination of those ideas but
the one the one thing you and I do have
going on is the fact that look man I
think it would take just as much time to
introduce a bunch of fairly simplistic
masks ask
superheroes for and in the show how
they've impacted the earth and show how
the Avengers are kind of jealous of them
or whatever I think you could show that
fairly easily showing me this dude with
all of his history without really
meeting Reed Richards is at the core I
understand it's really slick move
putting up with the Chawla I love that
and I wish they had the bravery to do
that but I don't think that they do I
think what we're actually gonna happen
is they'll figure out a way to encompass
mutants and Fantastic Four bring them
from where at all time line some weird
stuff like that they're kind of these
hokey heroes in this new age and it's
gonna be really cool and they're gonna
have their own sort of hokey Batman with
a you know Batman can do anything with
prep time so dr. doom dr. doom got a
spill for your ass you got an equation
for your ass you got some armor for your
ass he got that techno-magic yes he's
got the monarchy for your ass and got
new butts so I understand that but I
just think it would take respectfully I
think it would take as much movie to set
up him by himself as it would my entire
team so I just think I just want to take
that off the benefit of dr. doom right
is you want that new fan oohs took what
seven movies we earned it we built up to
it but if you introduced like five
members of a team or seven or nine
however many you get that's gonna be
really overwhelming for an audience I'm
like these are these guys in a
post-credits scene you'll learn them
later whereas if you tease dr. doom it's
on one individual to focus your
attention on I think you can slow burn
one more than you can slow burn it but
you're also introducing a country you're
introducing way more I'm introducing a
team you're introducing a country well I
would a lot of mass go ahead and make
your point and then roll right into your
final thoughts uh well I'll just I'll
just do my final thoughts right I I what
I want to say about mine is that like I
feel like it takes a lot of setup for
this that I think that's a good point it
takes a lot of setup for this for this
one it is
Scarlet Witch we know her we are
immediately in we we have never had her
powers clearly defined here's an example
for a chance for Marvel to define her
powers to see her come to her powers
maybe she and dr. stranger talking he
helps her unlock something I don't know
but you know we we get that moment of oh
we know her we immediately know her wait
what's wrong with her wait what is she
doing wait she can do what else oh [ __ ]
she could have done this the whole time
oh my god why and then you get that
switch and we don't necessarily need to
see like Cyclops and Wolverine and all
this other stuff and
if they wanted they could just be like
hey by the way all the x-men actors
you're you're over here now and we're
just gonna introduce you or we'll erase
whatever but like the x-men are known
entities we know who the x-men are we
know the Fantastic Four are more or less
and then it would be interesting to see
this alternate reality switch over where
you have scarlet like you have Peter
Parker as a celebrity now like he was in
house of M you have Carol Danvers as
like the princess of the earth and
everyone's like you know but then you
also have the Avengers having to deal
with all these very strange new mutant
powers they're already in place shield
is in place whatever else but then there
are those two Avengers like that one
Avenger who knows that this isn't right
and I don't know who that is I I'm not
the writer but like they're the ones
like Wolverine in house of M they have
to go then go get the other Avengers on
board that's the end of that first movie
is okay so we're not in the right
reality in our one of our own is the
problem oh my god what what do we do
then you go get a second movie because
again the end the question is who's the
big bad for the MCU that's not just a
movie it's not just Voltron
so like this gives us a couple movies to
to fully introduce this new idea and
then x-men are now in the universe we've
established them as the universe and
you're you are right there is a problem
with it like being taken like from a
negative but that can I feel like that
could be built over like yes there are
negative in this universe but they come
to see their their value all this other
stuff they prove themselves they
eventually start fighting along with the
Avengers in a lot of different ways and
then keep mutants and and it's all back
to normal and she disappears to Latveria
and I'm glad dr. das they're all right
like I said I I don't come to these
prepared to lose but I do understand
that it's hard for people to metabolize
how you could introduce a whole team but
again I taking someone else's villain is
very much a thing that works very well
in comics when you when when when Frank
Miller decided to take kingpin from
spider-man who had graduated above
street-level crime and give him to
daredevil it was more appropriate for
him it was a beautiful thing
by launch to hold like move meta comics
and I think we could do a similar thing
with with taking these taking the heroes
who have traditionally fought one guy or
faceless monsters and put them up
against people who represent exactly
what they are on the opposite side
much like distinguish competitions
things when the Justice League goes and
they see the League of injustice the I
mean the the jerks from the earth to
more invasive like Batman Batman's owl
man and even that's ultraman and they're
just these jerks it's like wow that's
how it be with no upbringing
yeah and that's how and maybe even the
rules in that other world work
differently to where evil behavior works
in that world and they're actually the
good guys but they're bad you mean
there's all sorts of ways you can go and
and and look at the the fallout of the
previous Avengers movies and what they
have wrought on other worlds I just
think that's really cool so like I said
I understand if it's not like
everybody's cup of tea but I just must
say I have to say Doctor Doom is a
fantastic for villain and I would love
to see maybe - maybe Black Panther goes
down to the barb rhenium mines and some
weird craft came straight out of a patch
of vibranium like what the hell sorry
son we had to use your vibranium to get
here from this from the negative zone
I'm Reed Richards and and and then and
then Doctor Doom is somehow being like
hey those are my prisoners is like wait
this is my country and all of a sudden
it's like no other I hate these guys and
they used to have some weird adventure I
can I can totally dig that but I think
it's his own thing and I think one thing
that we should gather from all these
arguments is the Marvel Universe I think
is ready to go in a different direction
I don't know if it's hysterical Phoenix
woman directions I don't know and I
don't know if it's take doom and given
the Black Panther direction but I think
and we can see a beautiful future of
Fantastic Four and black panther versus
doom and that's a movie you know things
of this nature and I would love for this
to be the start of it where it's just a
one-off movie where they fight some
super dudes and it's like three hours
long but a kicks but I'd love that
Thank You ed so we've said the MCU big
bad I've mentioned Doctor Doom and I was
saving fine final argument what I think
is the way to do it you introduce dr.
doom through Wakanda so through black
panther because that's a familiar force
you know black panther you know that
world so you meet Liberia you meet
kondeh I mean you mean Doctor Doom
through Wakanda but you introduced the
Fantastic Four through a Doctor Doom
movie no Holly's been directing and
developing a doctor new movie for a very
long time
I think the Fantastic Four because
Marvel needs to go in a new direction
should be introduced through their
antagonist we meet Doctor Doom through
Black Panthers so we already like that
universe and then that translates into
bring the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers don't necessarily even need to
be involved we've had a lot of Avengers
movies we can have pieces of it but I
say Doctor Doom is the slow burn he's a
post-credit he's a he's a post-credits
scene in one of the future movies then
he's a full character in black panther
which leads us to a antagonist as
Fantastic Four long ago sinister 6 was
being written with spider-man as the
antagonist by Drew Goddard and I thought
was the best idea that's the way to do
it you bring the Fantastic Four by
living in a single character that way
you can introduce them properly you find
out they're the good guys it's very
similar what you're saying is like oh
wait who's the good guy who's the bad
guy here Marvel has grown up to be
intellectual we want there to be plot
and want there to be smarts we want
enemy intellectualism we want to have
that Civil War flavor of the Accords we
want to evolve on that we want to evolve
in what powers great power and great
responsibility is the Doctor Doom story
especially the Reed Richards for me
house of them is a miniseries for me you
need a lot of story and if you're doing
both movies that can work but the plot
structure would be so difficult to have
like x-men introduced scarlet witch's
over here she's the bad guy she's the
good guy she's back on her movies wears
on a show which Disney Plus is doing
House of them can live beautifully and
that's how I'd love the x-men they
introduced and to be honest I've seen
squadron sabrine type things and the
boys is gonna be doing that the the
Marvel movies have had them fight
opposite versions themselves I don't
think Marvel lives there so I think the
most ncu thing that evolves the N see
you without betraying the MCU is
introducing dr. boom as a slow burn and
getting us Fantastic Four with John
Krasinski as Reed Richards and Emily
Blunt as Sue Storm
time there we go there is round 2
dan Morel please take us to the fact
zone and then give us your thoughts on
this our contestants are taking us to
the facts oh yes indeed it's not really
much I can add
Matt just really teed me up the house of
M ran from June to November of 2005
written by Brian Michael Bendis that's
all I have for actually thing else is
pretty much on point right on as far as
my opinion again that's the the
passionate fights are the hard ones and
the one was solid on the facts so I have
to go just off of what how things hit me
and the ones that I feel like I was on
board with the idea of Scarlet Witch at
the beginning and this idea of her of
her you know what has happened to her so
far sort of escalating into some kind of
crisis but I think the further on that
we got and the more it sort of ballooned
from Scarlet Witch to the outer
realities to now we're here and then
more than the x-men like I lost the ball
a little bit and I feel like a little
bit the same with Edie and I think
people hit ad as far as we've seen them
against opposite characters it's
introducing a whole team it just seemed
like there was a lot to do there and I
thought that the biggest through line
and the the big picture even though it
seems like the more obvious answer for
me was Doctor Doom in the sense of you
know coy very smartly saved a little bit
for the end there as far as how it's
gonna be introduced and why and how it
would fit in into walking to what we
already have and adding new things I
just felt like that was the most
cohesive for me so my vote goes to koi
1/4 koi lon what do you got yeah I
largely agree I I was really on board
with Edie I love the idea of like an all
reality superhero team that it's the
classic The Avengers but then I think by
the end they'd sort of already talked
him into like yeah this is really just
one awesome movie and I don't know if
this would work it's like a big bad for
all them and the questions really
who's the emcee you big bad man who
would be cool to see the Avengers fight
so it came down to Matt versus coy and
yeah I again I agree with Dan I thought
the eye of the red house of em and the
further we went in the description I
just started getting kind of confused
like so it's an alternate reality
there's a different earth but all the
Avengers are there and like the audience
wouldn't know at first that it's an
altered reality I wasn't sure how this
would work in a huge
universe with all these individual
movies so quois I thought did the best
job of like here's how it would fit in
it would work in sort of the background
at first and then we build and despite
the think about you know the argument
doombots I think it'd be cool to
squadron supreme was like we had to
question number three and it is again
koi one mat one and looking to get on
the board tie this bad boy up and let's
keep our our opening are just so yet can
I have time for a little bit more back
and forth opening arias just a tad
shorter and we'll jump right into it so
question three
we know Sam has becoming the new Captain
America we asked who should take Tony's
place as the new Ironman and this can be
an established or not as of yet
established character from the MCU and
it's question number three stars player
three mr. ed Grier okay now look I hate
to be this guy who's all like about the
the Mullins actually the question is but
the question is we know Sam is becoming
the new Captain America who should take
Tony's place as the new Ironman not the
new Big Brain of the Marvel Universe not
the new Time Machine tech tech and
technician no the new person who's
flying around with Jets going like this
mm-hmm going like this yes going like
this and that's Rhodey
that's Rhodey and he's earned it and
also one of the main things about our DJ
has a wonderful actor and the person who
kept this whole series together is the
fact that he's old he is an actor and he
can put some top spin on a line Don
Cheadle is arguably probably the second
or third best actor in this whole
enterprise and yes he's been shunted out
to a guy who wears a weird gray suit
with a Gatling gun on his shoulder but
over the course of these movies has
become more than that he wouldn't
he went to when he went to help nebula
with the power stone he's been
introduced to a larger cosmic
consciousness he's met he's met Carol
Danvers what the military connection
that they have and maybe another time
they got yeah you know and I just
believe he is a guy who we can put in
these situations and and and we can
explore the capabilities of a pilot a
real G pilot in that armor and they can
go a different route than him just being
so smart and just flying up to stuff and
going well I would use my nano gel to do
this in Meridian no he's just a pilot
simple maverick in that suit let's get
nuts
Chow you know I think they'll be able to
do some really interesting things with
the Iron Man character now that he isn't
so burdened with being the big brain of
the Marvel Universe which is why I'd
like a nice simple great actor in that
suit from now on and that's Rhodey all
right let's get nuts with Rhodey thank
you ad coy this is my first ever
contrarian answer on movie fights III
wanted to go home old and it actually
ties into my last answer and that is
there should be no next Iron Man Robert
Downey jr. started this franchise Robert
Downey jr. is the one that began this
universe Robert Downey jr. ends his arc
not just by dying but also by I am Iron
Man to me the next Iron Man should be
rewritten to me it should be someone not
taking up the mantle if everyone hands
off the mantle if if Sam gets the cap
shield and war machine becomes Iron Man
and we get Valkyrie as Thor then it
suddenly it to me it takes away from
Falcon s cap and it takes away from
Valkyrie store because then it's just oh
we've had a new trilogy these characters
are all just past on the torch there
there are seconds I want a new type of
character that is the type that Iron Man
he takes the leadership role he takes
the role of someone that is doing the
science he takes the role of someone
that is snarky but smarter than everyone
he takes the role of someone that has a
lot of burden he takes the role of
someone that actually Iron Man works
because he goes from genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist to someone that
is overburdened by the things he's seen
Reed Richards is the smartest guy in the
planet that broke his friends faces
enemy friends face and ruined his
family's life when you meet Reed
depending on how they did the origin
story he has the burden of Ironman one
through three built-in but if you cast
him right that is a leader that is a man
we need that is the science plus it
leans into the science I want someone
that continues on this message of kids
being smart as a positive kids when you
are smart you are a better person Reed
Richards and bodies that it is Marvel's
first family he is the leader of
Marvel's first family he can be the
leader of the Avengers I don't think we
need another Iron Man I think we need
another leader Thank You Oy
Matt I feel like my answer is kind of a
combination of both of these in a lot of
ways because I'm saying princess Shuri
two challahs sister we we met her in an
Black Panther and then saw her a little
bit more in an infinity war and in game
she has proven herself to be at least as
intelligent or close to his intelligent
as Robert Downey jr. despite being at
such a young age she creates the
technology like she created the black
panther suit that he's wearing that
takes all the like potential energy
converts it to kinetic energy or like
the gambit suit or whatever we want to
call it created and though we have not
seen her as a pilot yet I think that a
great way to introduce her as the new
Iron Man is to have Rhodey teach her how
to fly a suit I think she builds her own
suit and then Rhodey helps her fly it
and once she's learned how to do that
you do have a new Iron Man who is not
Iron Man you have a great a great
warrior she's proven herself to be a
great warrior but you also have a great
innovator you have a hyper intelligent
person who can solve like scientific
problems on the fly
and you you have her with the entire
resources of a nation behind her so
she's definitely a billionaire and
definitely a philanthropist so she
already is in a lot of ways Robert
Downey jr. is character just and a whole
other person in a whole other character
and she is basically the MCU equivalent
to riri Williams who takes over for
Ironman in the current current
publication canon so III really feel
like she is the embodiment of all of
those things she's not necessary
the Ironman she's not a leader you're
right but she does lead a nation she
could learn how to do that we just
haven't seen her do that yeah because
she lives under the you know I know she
well she lives in the shadow of her
brother but I think that also gives her
like the impetus to outgrow that to grow
beyond that and you know she wants to be
a warrior
all right fight it out you guys Cherie
Ring Williams doesn't work because
really is from the hood riri williams
overcame adversity by going to MIT on a
scholarship because she saw everyone
around her die for Miriam strength is
the fact that she saw her father die her
best friend died and then used that to
her advantage whereas where Sheree is
coming from the opposite perspective so
if you if you really up Sheree then
you're negating the RiRi side and that's
the beauty of Ironman so for me Sheree
is an amazing black panther that's why
she becomes my Panther she is the one
that goes hey T'Challa you're not the
only one in this family by the way I can
do it better than you and that's how she
becomes her own leader if you make her
Iron Man you're negating a better a
different Black Panther and yorda
gaining a better different Iron Man so
you're negating two amazing story lines
at once I love the idea of Shirin being
a part of the thing but everyone in the
comics know she's that and also we had
gank EB Med leads that already messed up
once we can't combine to that point
though you've that was a great takedown
I'll let you do that now on yours though
I think we've got us we've got like
we've got a similar situation with this
whole Reed Richards jazz because look
man the respect that this Marvel
Universe is going to give Tony Stark is
that it's going to take a consortium of
minds to make up for what he what he was
so the cosmic awareness of Carol Danvers
basically our rocket being out there in
space you're only a genius on earth pal
the whole great line the Hulk
given his new mental capacity Pym who's
still alive and kickin you know so I am
cherie and T'Challa I think they will
form like the Alpha Flight they will
form like the mind Illuminati that that
sees the galactic threats that may be
coming for us
it requires us and all kind of jazz you
mean I think they're going to do that I
think I put in Reed Richards in there
negates 22 movies give or take of
setting up these people who are going to
carry the torch and we're talking about
Karen
Torche and this I'm not gonna give you
you just wandered out of the crowd Reed
Richards I'm not gonna give you the
Olympic torch I'm not I mean I'm not
gonna give Sheree I believe what Kois
that was very good you're taking away
her ability to be the Black Panther in
in in the child's absence or in his
disgrace if that should be a story
Landon comes you're denying her that
stuff every bring her but with Rhodey
you're doing simply what the comics did
when Tony got too drunk his homey said
dude I'll hold you down I won't even let
people know you're all messed up like
this
I'll even pretend to be you a selfless
act of being inside the Ironman suit so
I believe rody has earned the right to
drive the damn car so it's very similar
we're covering the same point I think
warmachine deserves me war machine not
the Ironman I love war machines
character we haven't gotten to see it
Don Cheadle is a very different man than
Downey jr. they're they're not gonna
call any other character Iron Man there
won't be another Iron Man so for me if
Reed takes on the mantle of that leader
I think we should have less Avengers
stuff for a while I think we should lead
in a new direction lean into this new
characters we get to play with do more
individualized movies and have the Iron
Man stand-in be a totally different
character that's not leading Avenger so
you get to keep your Illuminati you get
to finally get a war machine with you
which I think we deserve but it's not
gonna be in the way that Iron Man was an
Iron Man movie I think war machine
should be about the having a disabled
character actually be disabled I think
that warmachine movie should be about
being the maverick pilot but that isn't
an Iron Man character that's a war
machine character mine is all of the
Iron Man things without sacrificing the
man's original adventures are
straight-up war machine adventures of
the first iron man half of it is like
Iron Eagle but he's inside the plane as
soon as the plane yeah I mean he's he's
going on a non-sanctioned all these
burning fools up yeah like I think war
machine could do stuff like that and I
think they could take some cues from
when Punisher got into the war machine
armor the sort of like stripped down I
don't have all this cosmic jazz on my
mom
I'm just like yo what's up put that
injustice is not that's not an Iron Man
yeah that's a war machine movie and I'm
in I'm on board I'm absolutely on board
for so that's that's not that's not part
of the arguments like Jermaine or Tito
the next Iron Man you have to define who
was Iron Man Iron Man was a billionaire
philanthropist like a super-duper hyper
intelligent person who created their own
technology and then defended the world
using that technology and that is cherie
and that is rear its and that's why they
get to do their own stuff with their own
crap you you are telling me that this
person who has piloted this machine this
war machine this whole time is somehow
less qualified to be the Iron Man analog
let's say because we've all picked apart
this matrix as much and they're not
about to call Sheree Iron Man Reed
British nor war machine fair but he
might be the iron patriot he might be
all kind of jazz so I just really
believe that that war machine getting to
again drive the car yeah it's like it's
like its Bonnie from Knight Rider I
finally got to do hey Michael Knight's
all laid up you got to drive the car and
have your own adventure and kiss a boy
oh yeah I love that aspect of it of like
and again a person who isn't burdened by
all this cosmic stuff who's just like
I'm flying the suit and I'm doing
earthly business with it I think a war
machine movie at him being the analog
for Iron Man the better one that you
guys is you know I think that that movie
we could really work and be you guys are
saying that it should be less Avengers
this stripped-down not so cosmically
aware of everything not so way to the
world just like I have I'll go solve
this and just I'll be Kane and kung-fu
with a set of armor hmm you mean I'll
deal with my disability in my van well
I'm like all this jazz I love that
aspect of thank you for giving that to
me because that's that's gonna add some
patos to what would normally just be a
revenge commando with armor on sort of
movie I think he's just brody man he
even got to be Iron Man in the Secret
Wars
Rodi Rodi Edie I thank you coy I love
the idea of that movie but we've had it
Iron Man one was him taking care of
things in other parts of the country and
other comes
trees Iron Man 2 was him being taken
like he was demon in the bottle he was
not able to control himself he was going
through his own stuff that wasn't cosmic
he was dealing with all that stuff so
for me we've already had that Iron Man
movie and I would love to see a war
machine movie that was the the top gun
maverick situation but that could be a
great Carol Danvers I war machine
situate like it doesn't land for me as
anything we have already seen before
unless they go in different directions
so for me that isn't the Iron Man of the
future
I love Sheree but I I think that the
reassuring thing is a dangerous thing
because you like I said negating 2
characters and I think Sheree needs to
grow into the Black Panther and leads to
lean into her ancestry in her history
and like I want to see more of that
realm and I want to see more of like you
know the the undead I want to see her
ancestry tied in I don't necessarily
want to see her as an Iron Man type
because that brings her over to us and I
want to see the world grow with mine the
world grows and we keep going under
galactic we go out as much as we want to
but it doesn't sacrifice what Iron Man
represents to the team what he
represents to the MCU and rip what he
represents to me Matt I love the idea of
Rhodey
but I love the idea of a war machine
movie I don't know that he could like I
mean it's hard to say someone's gonna
take the place of iron man cuz iron man
was so many different things but I feel
like we've already seen a lot of the
stuff that you're talking about in
regards to war machine I think we would
see it from a different perspective and
I think that's wonderful
but I don't know that that makes him
then the next Iron Man for the the the
semantics of the rhetoric of the
question same for you like Reed is a big
brain absolutely he's a giant brain he's
a fantastic brain and he's one of the
best brains in the MCU and yes like the
MCU is going to go in a new direction
but the question wasn't where's MCU
gonna go with and who's their next big
brain gonna be it was who's the next
iron man iron so you have to define who
Iron Man is Iron Man is hyper
intelligent philanthropist billionaire
or whatever else but also innovative
technologist who creates their own suit
and then goes out and fights injustice
and that is Sheree you don't have to
take the black panther stuff away from
her she's still a warrior she can build
a flying black panther suit which is
even cooler than her brothers black
panther suit she can be like flying
black
we're not gonna call her probably
ironheart was she and you're right
she isn't RiRi Williams but she also has
had her own share of adversity and who's
to say that she's not gonna have
adversity and grow out of that adversity
when she takes on the mantle of iron
woman or iron man or whoever you know
whatever they name her or black panther
who can fly like like like you can still
give her that adversity without taking
it away from RiRi so that's like I feel
like if you're gonna say who's the next
Iron Man RiRi Williams make sure he
makes the most sense sorry time all
right good stuff you guys
yeah factually I mean once again we've
confirmed that these guys know their
shape all right you start us off class
great great arguments I like all these
characters I like all of these scenarios
but I have to say in terms of just the
question that was asked who would take
over the mantle who would be the Next
Iron Man whether or not they're called
Iron Man I thought ed really had the
strongest answer for the question made
the most sense in terms of here's why
roadies the character we've already
established who would come in and pick
up this mantle I thought Matt anyways
answers were great for like how should
we sort of consider what the smartest
characters and the Marvel Universe are
gonna be doing from here on out but I
thought in terms of the question asked
about Iron Man I thought I had really
nailed it get out of my brain long
because I thought the same thing ahead
you get the point
going to the tiebreak tiebreaker jte
let's see a tiebreaker graphic all right
so this works thusly just like speed
round so I will ask the question shout
out your answers and then you'll have 20
seconds to elaborate in the order we
heard the answers then we'll come back
around for 10 second rebuttals okay cack
is the speed round or toy there's a
tie-break that works just like the speed
round okay cool
right yes dan is all tossed over that's
down
ding-ding here we go keeping it Marvel
centric now that Thor is possibly
joining the guardians who should
Valkyrie team up with for a new
adventure
Captain Marvel oK we've kept Marvel beta
ray bill say that one more time beta ray
bill beat beta ray bill great Korg
couldn't get past Korg I was just like
right on the order we heard it was Eddie
coy Matt edy 20 seconds begin when you
speak I think it's a very simple
correlation between a Valkyrie and
Captain Marvel habitat adventure yes
she's gonna be the king of new a scar
but also she's gonna get that itch to go
out to outer space
who's the best consort slash liaison
slash bodyguard from space his Captain
Marvel them having world bending
adventures meeting the crazy space
people having a having first contact
with different alien species having
granted the time wait we've only touched
on it so far Iron Man 3 almost gave us a
buddy cop movie I want a real buddy cop
movie and that is gonna be Valkyrie in
beta ray bill beta ray bill can fill you
in on all the stuff Thor legacy all of
the history of Thor all of the back and
the day stuff with all the hammers we
can actually explore the Thor mythos
beyond just Thor and we can go cosmic
and then go to this world I wanna see my
Pegasus stuff I want to see more
Ragnarok stuff I want to grow that world
and bitter in bills Ben I want for the
entire MCU he's the answer he is the way
to do it and complete a new genre for
mortal and I'd love to see them to
picked him up alright Matt I think that
we can do some fun with her being the
new king of new Asgard or the new queen
and Korg has has some issues back home
that he needs to get home to and they
have to leave together
and we get that awesome buddy cop movie
that you're talking about because he is
such a weird character and she doesn't
understand his ways and he doesn't
understand hers and
is noble and he's just like oh hey man
what's going on and we get a lot of
comedy out of that 10-second rebuttals
and the two most brazen women in the
Marvel Universe I'm knockin around
guardians of the galaxy stay out there
through the galaxy drink it giant
flagons of mead punching holes and
world's decided me up for that that's a
buddy cop movie I'm glad we over Graham
buddy cop I'd see your movie when it was
a force I think that's more likely to
happen in your movies just those
Darryl's kids who have already had on
YouTube either of these can exist but
only one of these is the buddy cop movie
we deserve in this beta ray bill where
else battery bill gonna come in it is
the time it is the place it is right now
better and build her I don't want to
rebuttal because I like both of your
answers so much I want to see you both
those movies way more than I want to see
your cork movie so that's my rebuttal no
that's what I want to toward you to vote
I'm being honest but I resigned and IKEA
yeah ground but Matt thank you for
playing with your heart and I want to
see both of those movies way more than I
want to say
you know I want to see all three of
those movies but right now I'm going to
Siena and Cory okay here we go
nice soft-spoken New Zealand accent all
right here we go
so speed right so it is one one that did
not count for a point Matt thank you for
just good valiantly and intelligently
the entire time good stuff how about to
do it here we are we're tied 1-1 Edie
and coy it works the same as the
tiebreak we just did I'll ask the
questions shadow at your answers in
twenty second twenty second then ten
second rebuttals got it let's do this
infinity war or endgame oh that's the
question yeah what's better what do you
like better what's better endgame all
right
Edie you got infinity war by default uh
coy
twenty seconds begin when you speak in
game isn't just a movie it's a
reinvention of the sequel only endgame
could do what it did because its delete
above 21 other films it is a 22 movie
series it uses time travel uses all the
things that Marvel does well it does
face mapping technology plus CGI it
couldn't exist unless you're invested in
each and every character eats in every
location Howard Stark and Tony's scene
alone is worth the president mentioned
plus all the action stuff plus all the
fanservice plus all the world lit
literally redefines what it means to be
a series and that movie is said of you
I'm and infinity war introduces you to a
villain where you're Loki gladdy one and
that is a feat period all of the action
all of the payoffs from 22 years without
getting to I watch them my grandma
watched that movie and understood every
piece of it you can't say that about in
game it is perfect in the same way that
something like Empire Strikes Back is I
like the density of it I like that it's
dense and I think is hard to understand
but you get the Winter Soldier payoffs
you get the Avengers past all those
things I love the villain we've had good
villains before we've never had a movie
that actually ties in 21 other films
because it's not possible Plus using all
the technology that's only available
today
we've literally never had a villain even
close to that notice and that is the
universal basically consensus besides
perhaps kill monger casinos had his own
story and we would almost almost ended
up rooting for him at the end time oh
boy uh you know I was I was fully on
board with coy but then just Ed's just
low-key confidence in the way so I don't
know yeah I think he just hypnotized me
ed and I gotta I gotta go infinity war
with Edie long yeah I actually agree I
was with I was with Corey for most the
time but I thought coy ultimately was
just like it wasn't it's not possible to
sort of tie all these movies together
and that that is true but it's also kind
of both infinity war endgame or kind of
an endgame or kind of tying everything
together and I thought its point about
Thanos being this sort of you know
different landmark villain was really
good so yeah I'm going it as well
alright and you take two one lead going
into question number two the speed round
here it is who will be missed more from
the regular MCU lineup Ironman or
Captain America okay we got cap from
Edie
we got Iron Man four coy at twenty
seconds we can when you speak Iron Man
is great but our DJ is such a beautiful
brilliant actor that we always knew that
at some point we were gonna lose him to
greater endeavors whereas Captain
America basically made a star we grew up
in our love of Chris Evans by watching
this character he grew before our eyes
from a new master to a straight-up
captain so I just think that we're gonna
miss that overall arc more even than
Kobe sacrificed
it wasn't about which is a better actors
out which character anastomosis and for
me do you brought an Iron Man into a
Captain America movie because of how
much we need Iron Man to balance out cap
I think Iron Man is his own entity the
cab movies might be better but Iron Man
himself is the most he's actually better
than the character of the comics he made
the character better can't say that
necessarily back cap Iron Man lives and
breathes Downey jr. and without him
there's a very different MCU going
forward no matter what no matter how you
shape it and throw all of them are was
the through lensman Iron Man Chris Evans
is a portrayal of Captain America is in
the same way superior to the common Bush
cat
America I never done captain America
till I could look into these the steely
blue eyes and brown rump the Ark of
Downey jr. Ironman is so dense cuz it
was about fathers and sons is better
overcome University I'm not doing all
those things and that represents what
the Marvel Universe represents it's not
just a piece of it as the entirety but
it's about being an adult and that is
what we get these movies out of for me I
think I like Ed's opening but I feel
like coy won me over
eventually by talking about how I even
represented not just a strong character
but a huge piece of the storytelling
that resonated with me a little bit more
so I'm gonna go with coy okay that's one
for point long yeah I agree if the
question was who gives the better
performance throughout the MCU I think
ed would have probably won but I think
if we're talking about this who's gonna
be missed more I think coy really sold
me on the crucial miss of Tony Stark so
I'm going going
all right coy you just tied it up but
now it's Boston zone for seven laughs
yes you took down America's ass question
number three the speed round we were all
tied up again slugfest here which
endgame daddy is more thick which n
games daddy is more thick yeah - Thor
Thor or Thanos yeah Thor all right
that's a star course clarification thick
is spelled a thi cc important okay
so again you said Thor yeah yeah okay we
got Thor we got sick Thor and thick
Thanos
add 20 seconds between you speak thick
from thick with two CS in the internet /
Street / whatever vernacular does mean
sexy as well as big so you can't argue
that chris hemsworth gone to see there's
still sexier than a nutsack chen monster
who wanted to kill everyone okay so yes
thick thor is thicker more sexy thick
fat whatever you want to call it and a
good guy okay there are hundreds of
means about how thick fantasies there
are not that many about four because
thick also implies a mental sexiness you
know who's got to stuff together Thanos
he has compassion he's going from one
specific thing he's trying to save
everyone like you just argued and he's
muscular underneath all that he keeps it
all together
he is felt and thick at the same time he
wears that armor proudly his thickness
is more beautiful even purple and I
think it's not fair to jump to my his
face this thickness is everything face
is part of it bro face is part of it and
I don't want that section monsters
trying to bug me and trying to mount me
so I but but Thor he just Nestle you you
know Thanos smells better than fix Thor
and you know that's a big part of it you
also know the Lebowski is not gonna get
up and do very much whereas thick Thanos
is the most motivated guy in the
universe I'll take that thick any day
and we all know what he wants some
ant-man and that's another conversation
oh yeah I I feel like yeah coy just got
me with love would that would that
rebuttal around right there so I'm going
clay Dan I enjoyed boys embrace of the
all the aspects of things not just
appearance but also motivation
drivability they're like
I feel like there's an extra sea and
thanks for everything and koi you gave
me that ecstasy I gotta go
hey you're all you're all thinking my
book all right so coy takes a 3-2 lead
and here is question number 4 of this
video by the way this game point for koi
you need this to keep her going mr. ed
Google mr. n you'll be first room awake
at night and then Google mister you're
not Google mr. Edie and carrot okay here
we go game point coy which Marvel movie
would you want to see characters revisit
via time-travel mm-hmm
which MCU movie would you want to see
but it says Marvel movie could be any
more or MCU I think we were leaning it's
an MCU there which MCU movie would you
want to see characters revisit via
time-travel that said blade if it was
marble an MCU blade I'm gonna say The
Incredible Hulk incredible okay we heard
blade first Incredible Hulk second coy
20 seconds when you speak the movie that
started the genre should be revisited
because it's out of genre that movie was
an action film that happen be a snow
myrtle character that's a great rate of
being more pathos more distinguished
more elements to the Marvel Universe
plus we need to bring in blame we need
to bring in another character like that
we need to bring in that 90s flavor
without it being a reference to the 90s
later buddy Captain Marvel meets blade
meets all of that universe and it brings
us back to the actual very beginning
where it all really started plus we need
Wesley Snipes and that's the best time
Wesley so you're trying to make a whole
movie I think this is like a one-off gag
much like the ones in endgame and what I
would love to see is after the
abomination had wiped
Harlem's but with Hulk's face for three
hours then shield shows up and put some
zip ties on them and throws them where
are you gonna store this guy see the
scene after the scene where you store
this guy he beat the Hulk up for two
hours where are you gonna store this guy
if we're making it one scene it's
bleeding walking
of the rave with all the blood you see
the Marvel Universe land outside and
there's no coups and you see blade just
come from there like who is this guy how
is he part of our universe I would take
that in a second that's a noodle way to
tie it all together and to show the
range mam University I want to see the
abomination wake up and smack the hell
out of everybody jump out of the
helicopter and land in the ocean now
there's no Godzilla in the Marvel
Universe if we don't know we're gonna
show up I love that time okay long I
love the abomination clean up stuff
which makes it does it doesn't make a
lot of sense of the original movie but I
do they are they overall I think boy has
a better clearer picture of what this
would be like and how it would sort of
fit in the universe I'm going with coy
Dan see I'm going with Edie for this
reason which is that canonically if this
were a comic book you could bring blade
back as he is but in our real world we
cannot bring 1998 Wesley Snipes back to
today but I just mean Wesley Snipes is
wonderful and he should be in more
things but I don't know if we have 1998
Wesley Snipes with us still I want to
remember blade as he was and so I am
gonna go an EDD because I do it at least
serves a function of answering a
question quite frankly I didn't know I
had until this moment now I need time
travels very compelling alright it's one
for quite one friend yeah I gotta go
with lon Ron's argument but for Edie
I thought Edie fit it in a little bit
more perfectly it was so concise and
precise his vision for that and so much
so it caused coy to change the framework
of his answer in the rebuttal round so I
gotta go add we are all tied up this is
a great moment in
the final question of you know what we
have we've reached the end game right
here let's do this
whoever takes this way and evolve it
you've all been fantastic by the way
saturday on vermeer gomorrah or black
widow get more to me tomorrow yeah okay
yeah okay
and we heard you first with Gomorrah koi
you're coming up next with Black Widow
what's truly sad about that final act is
that Venice she found out in that moment
that Dennis actually had loved something
the last thing you are cognizant of is
the fact that your dad loved you and
then you die that my friend has had it's
not a heroic sacrifice it's you being
duped by your own father's love
similarly I love that we realized how
much they both loved each other and that
was the beautiful set up and it was it's
way more sad to have lost everything to
the point in the last five years you've
been slowly dying inside so the last
thing you can do is die suicide by a
hero is the saddest possible thing and
two people trying to kill themselves to
the other is tragic in its own right she
killed herself because of how much he
loved Hawkeye and in turn how much
Hawkeye loved her plus it was the end of
Black Widow carrot we grew up with I'd
argue that heroic sacrifice is not sad
it is it is the glory of the warrior and
it is what what was given to Tony Stark
when he sacrificed himself and Black
Widow got some semblance of that but it
wasn't a samurai death like Tony Stark's
was it was literally leaping off a cliff
to save her best friend who she loves so
nearly they had to fight over it was
much more sad to see a character we've
lived with eight years with think of
more who's had a very tricky plot point
Black Widow is us she's all of us oh man
this is a very difficult one I you know
I feel like Edie had the great parry
with the hero's death and it set coy on
his heels a little bit and we didn't
hear enough to take down Gomorrah so I
so by a hair I gotta go
dan I think that it was a great opening
salvo to talk about the tragic thing of
learning your parent loves you right
before you die and I thought it was a
great parry to mention that it was not
necessary ascetic hero's death I think
that was a great response I also have to
go with that and you just took the movie
vines Wow Burnie what a journey
yes let me tell you something getting on
TV was easier than winning this you all
dug deep and that just to answers the
level of knowledge today thank you for
fascinating entertaining fights today
you guys and please tell us where we can
find you yeah well you can check me out
on comedy central
they've really loaded up to the app so
people who don't have cable can watch me
do stand-up show called the news I've
seen and do stand-up you are a funny
gentleman oh very funny
very funny thank you very much my pin
tweet on Ed Greer destroys at you know
on Twitter you can check out my pin it's
a it's a bit from the show and please
support and check out my podcast nerd
goat podcast we do deep dives with
people like yourselves about who your
favorite character is who is your nerd
greatest of all time we've had everybody
from James Bond to jocular though ever
you know and it's really a great fun
celebratory podcast we're not nitpicking
when i tear anything apart we're
celebrating these characters and the
majesty that they encompass and i'm
really happy to be part of that culture
and well fought congrats on the victory
great to have you man matt key well
fought as well thank you and yeah we're
always great to have you and here please
tell us
my twitter is at the matki i I've got
I'm between gigs right now but you know
you can catch old episodes on my comic
book show the Wednesday Club on the geek
and sundry twitch key questions up there
still - yeah like I'm onwards to the
next best things face for face for yes
sir thank you Matt coy oh boy Wow took
it to the limit
Oh Shelley but yeah great stuff my man
please yeah just say some stuff hunt me
down on clutter heroes every week we
also brought back comic book shopping
which is uh the show i watch the most on
collider now I'm honored to do it we've
met a David Harbor on Zack Levi on we've
got some really great guests coming up
in June especially some really cool
people are coming in and then also this
week alone we've had jim Starlin who
invented Thanos Brian Michael Bendis on
my favorite writers of all time and
Deadpool's own Rob Liefeld so a bunch of
like the 80s 90s and today of comics so
that's all gonna be on Collider and then
just a whirlwind and also I am doing
some stuff at Skybound which is very
much this world's alley so they'll be
announced really soon and it's been an
absolute pleasure and this is my
favorite place to nerd out man I just
like having like mighty foes to mess
with movie trivia is insane like I'm
always so sweaty at the end I'm so glad
there's nobody because I'm always just
wiping yeah yeah yeah bring a jacket
it's not the best idea
yeah yeah you know you guys rose to the
top like cap Thor and Iron Man today you
guys were great gambrel on Harris Merlin
the magical Merlin Dan what do you see
taken is any gonna take it again
oh yes my apologies to the ugly dolls
but in how do you think long shots gonna
do long shot I ever ething is gonna do
about a hundred and sixty million
dollars less than in fairness thank you
Dan uh blonde Harris thank you for a
really very little this time yeah yeah I
mean you you provided important opinions
I mean you were doing the Lord's work
tell us where we can find you my me on
Twitter at lol s that's where I am BAM
Ron Harris sleek and easy yes
follow along everybody here please
follow me at how Rudnick on Twitter and
Instagram putting up a lot of just dumb
stuff about movies and TV and comedy etc
and I gotta say
hoot hoot owl nation participants in the
house he's doing a ok I want to thank
everybody for watching JT could we see
that al picture over time see you next
week
thanks JT abilities
[Music]
you